all right my topic for this lecture is
what is classical mathematics and you
all are probably thinking that's a
really good question isn't just math
math math has always been math and to a
certain extent I think that's exactly
right
there's some content that's pretty
universal so think of something like the
Pythagorean theorem quadratic formula
you know addition problems are still
addition problems we still use the same
kind of operations and I think the thing
that ends up distinguishing classical
mathematics from something that might be
done at a non classical school is
actually how we what we do with that
content how we deliver it to students
how students learn it how students that
really come to understand it and grasp
it and so what I want to pitch today is
classical mathematics actually as a
fusion of a couple of things right and
the first one here I think is needs to
be a fusion of both procedural fluency
right how you do the things we do as
mathematicians right how we add subtract
we want our students to graduate
being able to know you know all the four
basic operations know how to factor
things etc we want them to be able to do
a certain number of things want to know
the procedures right but we also really
want them to have a conceptual
understanding of the things right we
don't want them just to know how to
divide we want them to know why we bring
this number down when we bring it down
we want them to know you know why the
Pythagorean theorem works right these
kind of things and so this fusion really
that we're aiming for in classical
mathematics here is really the what's
and the whys right that their skills are
supported by a deeper understanding
right and also their understanding is
informed by this practice and repetition
that they have done here so right so as
teachers we have our students over and
over and over repeating different things
to practice until there may make it
perfect right
we also have them saying it's not just
good enough to be able to know that you
know when I have this certain formula up
here I follow the formula I plug it in
and I get an answer right I know you
know why that formula comes about and
forms other formulas etc and right so
we're really aiming for in this
classical pedagogy right is this fusion
of both of these into one sort of
central combination of procedural and
conceptual the other thing that I think
it's a fusion of is this idea of things
that are done by the teacher they're
delivered by the teacher to students
right as well as this idea of student
driven explorations so this might be
something that I as a teacher sort of
really guiding my students through I'm
asking them a bunch of questions here
I'm the one that's kind of making making
the material come alive but I also don't
want to just hand in the answers right
well my favorite quotes about
mathematics is mathematics is the art of
explanation right if we do all the
explaining to the students right
we actually rob them of the mathematics
themselves itself right and so what we
really want is our students to be able
to explore and to drive their
exploration into the topics right if you
think about teaching multiplication
right I don't I do want to be able to
tell the students you know
multiplication is this active repeated
addition but I also want them to be able
to experience multiplication right I
want them to be able to say to answer
their question you know how do we figure
out how many feet we have as a class
right and get them counting by twos and
get them being the ones saying I don't
need to ask every single person how many
feet they have every one has two feet
and so I can do two times the number of
people in the class right and so we have
this student driven sort of exploration
right and I think the fusion here that
lies at the center is this idea of these
kind of conversations right and so the
teachers are asking these pointed these
meaningful questions to students and the
students are engaging in those things by
engaging in those questions with their
own ideas right and so me as a teacher
is this dynamic in engagement with the
students around this meaningful topic
right
so I think you are right math is math is
math right it's always been math it's
the same kind of content but I think
what separates this idea of classical
mathematics is
not just jamming content into kids heads
over and over and over again until they
get it and we're not just turning them
loose to say go for go to explore all
the math that you want to write it's
this dynamic fusion of the what's and
the whys right within this kind of
conversation type structure right and
that I think is really what's gonna make
classical what make mathematics
classical